I think I know why you don't like this
woman yes it's because she reminds you
of yourself oh my god Wow thank you for
coming
Edmund Tran Lucy James and Michael hi um
you all have one thing in common
apart from working with me in games but
which is that you all like the sign of
five and this year we have two percent
of five games coming
so let's decide which confidants suck
and which ones are good yes
via the means of battle royale it's kind
of a battle royale what we're gonna do
is a single elimination bracket where
we're going to decide in groups of two
knockout rounds who is the ultimate
confidante and we can rag on confidence
and we will pick our wife ooh and I
realized right before this that I think
we all have the same waifu but let's go
around and check on the count of three
ready three two one Makoto yeah it's
more the whole thing but I kept telling
I kept telling Jess you know it's it's
about the journey not the destination so
you know yeah and the first round is a
hell of a round to kick off it's a
helluva round and thank you for leading
us off because I was clearly not going
to do it in any concise way the first
round is Makoto and Yashida
so uh I'm anime Bernie Sanders yeah
that's right I'm gonna leave the floor
open to you guys poor Yashida
okay Jamie saved what do we like the
sheet up I like him a lot and I think
all of us do as well because he's a very
good representation of a mentor for the
main protagonist and he's also kind of
an embodiment of is like the polar
opposite of who the main villain is and
as someone who's kind of interested in
how politics kind of dictates the story
of persona he's like one of those
figures that you kind of root for and
Yoshi has also been through a lot of
stuff himself he was also a victim of a
corrupt system and had his career ruined
and the arc of him kind of coming to
terms with that is was heartwarming and
you know as the protagonist as the
player you learn a lot
from that and it goes hand-in-hand with
the themes of persona 5 so having that
character there who's more of a like a
socialistic kind of icon for the story
is you know I
that's my guy I made sure I ranked I got
ranked 10 with him so it's very
important to me he doesn't give up to
like like because Joker is put in some
really bad situations and so was the
Shido and like seeing this guy just like
trudge it out and like just take the
crap that's getting throwing at him is
very inspiring and I really like you see
de whereas a lot of the other confidants
I had like Inklings of like know about
that bet you she was like a good guy
through and through but he didn't have a
motive oh that's the thing you're always
rooting for him and in terms of the
broader range of confidence and people
that you would encounter in persona 5 I
loved him I loved his storyline but he
doesn't have a nuclear powered motorbike
that's true I'm afraid I mean
unfortunately yeah and you bring it back
around to Makoto and we may as well just
get this done early Makoto is the best
she's one of the more special characters
in the game if not be one because of I
love her design obviously and her
juxtaposition between how she's a very
diligent student and how she kicks ass
in the Metaverse is a dynamic that I
really dig and also her relationship
with her sister signing Jamaa who's a
very important character at the game -
there's another dynamic there and how
her background with her father and the
reason why she's fighting and the reason
why she wants to get involved in justice
system all of that is kind of it feels
full it sounds like it's time to
possibly put your Sheeta out of his
misery so we're gonna do what we're
gonna do with every one of these rallies
and vote and you have to vote between
one of the two of the pairs so are we
going Makoto oh shoot oh look we know we
know how to take the vote this time
we've got some some you know not so in
your potty characters but they are ones
that you have to level up and I have
left out any of the characters who
automatically level up that you don't
actually have to spend time with so this
time we have Mifune and a why why is
your doodoo cells you guns for my Yakuza
and Mifune is the fortune teller who you
can't talk to unless you pay her money
when you level her up though she does
give you a really useful you pay her
money and you can rank up faster
however the Y has the better storyline
he's the gruff guy the gruff exterior
with the heart of gold adopting the kids
he's trying to run away from his dark
past and help others was like what
storyline and also the music and the gun
shop absolutely slaps absolutely slaps
so I think we know lies detective amen
any adult cool enough to like give me
guns is OK in my book whoa whoa relax bi
uie why is is great III think that
because he's very integral to the kind
of the cycle of playing the game because
you go see him so often because you want
to upgrade your equipment so he's very
present throughout the game and like I
said the music kind of attaches to the
the vibes that he gives off and he's
he's another mentor type I suppose and
someone who has like that's a consistent
thing across all the characters is that
they've been through a lot themselves
who have been screwed over by the system
in some sort of way and that's exactly
Joker story it's unfortunate because uh
she hi a buffoon a she's she can be a
great character but unfortunately I
missed a lot of it because I wasn't
aware of how to pursue it because of
like a I'm trying to keep my end because
I'm trying to upgrade my equipment sorry
and it's it's I imagine a lot of people
kind of missed her storyline but having
actually seen it through in a second
playthrough it's uh it's actually really
good
so who gets your vote she cons you out
of the money that I like she's she is a
con artist for a lot of that hot
I mean con artists Yakuza selling guns
to kids I mean it's a good matter for me
akiza I'd rather give my money to my for
sure why all right yeah yeah so we
talked about guardians so this is good
because our next matchup has secured
Sakura yo Guardian and Shinya Oda King
in the arcade dude who also likes guns
no definitely fake one yeah hey kid get
out of here I kind of I'm with you I
mean I can't go past uh Cara as much as
he hates you in the beginning the
relationship you've formed with him is
so worth putting the time in it's it's
it feels so truly paternal and you can
feel that they grow to love each other
and like that that just can't be beat at
this Brown was always got like way
better style he's white hat and suit
it's top notch no I mean he makes a mean
cup of coffee and a great plate of curry
so and he who takes care of you
the thing about soujiro is it's kind of
part and parcel to his arc is that and
when I first played this game and I was
like man this dude is buggin I'm about
to knock this fool out because he gives
you gives you such a hard time and the
opening hours he's like damn I got to
take care of this stupid-ass kid he's
gonna live in my attic he better not
mess with no customers I'm barely making
enough money to keep the shop open and I
was like wow wow thanks man he think I
want to be here but of course he comes
around and and it's not just like oh
yeah you're a good kid after all it's
it's again like it's another one of
those arts Redemption arts I guess where
he's been through a lot himself and also
how his obviously his story ties to
Futaba
and how hard it is for him to be a
parent kind of plays into why he's so
like such a hard-ass to begin with and
he's he's integral to the story and I I
think that you know I I didn't like Oda
all that much because he's like I mean I
kind of respect him but he's kind of
he's kind of a little he's a little [ __ ]
at the beginning okay his storyline the
kid it's it's fine you kind of play the
big the oldest sibling role but it's not
the same as watching this Iceman melts
over time and then by then you genuinely
feel like you have this real strong
connection with him this paternal
relationship with him and I mean just as
you get towards the end of the game and
the way that you can tell how much
they'll love each other it's just yeah
it's probably it's probably like the
most important relationship of the game
for me like I love it so let's see what
I'm going for and the next matchup is
not much harder because it's um a great
character with who I think is the worst
character in the game it's on and oh
yeah the paparazzo journalist oh yeah
who I know every time I had to go talk
to it I would put it off like I she
doesn't do anything I'm 90% sure I can't
remember very specifically but I'm 90%
sure the stuff you get from her
confident levels isn't even good it's
just there's no point to her defense I
do like the anime archetype of the the
tired adult who who drinks a lot but can
function while drunk and that's her so
I'll give her that
relatable I think I know why you don't
like this woman yes I think it's because
she reminds you of yourself oh my god so
I Romans on oh my first playthrough
however it's one of those ones where you
kind of do it by accident but I wasn't
unhappy about it
because I loved on I loved it kind of
feels weird to say that I love her she
looks but I love I love her design I
really love it and I think she looks
fantastic and I just think she's very
sweet and she's kind of she's got a lot
of heart I have a lot of respect for on
as a character because she's kind of the
catalyst for the opening of the game and
it's like yo it's it's why when I think
about what the opening of persona 5 is
now because my first impression of the
game and it is wild it is bold and it
kind of revolves around her and her
friend Shiho and how dedicated she is to
her friend because she owes like her
only friend because everyone it's really
weird to think that oh the beautiful
popular girl is the one who's getting
picked on she's the most lonely out of
everyone at that school and yeah this is
how all those these D seemingly
disparate characteristics of her kind of
come together to actually make sense in
that regard on I think is an incredibly
well done character man she goes through
a lot of [ __ ] and then to come out on
the other end as one of the key
characters who's alongside everyone the
whole time is yeah it's beautiful
all right well let's move on so the next
matchup we've got is Haru and Mishima so
one thing I will say about Haru is that
for me she came into the game too late
for me to form a real kind of bond with
her and so I feel like I'm waiting on
royal to come out so I can play through
and kind of prioritize all of her
confident stuff because I just feel like
she's it's a bit of a missed opportunity
her storyline like trying to escape from
an abusive potentially abusive
relationship is super powerful I just
feel like I didn't invest enough into it
so that's my bad
it's nothing against her but that's
that's my perspective on on her as a
character whereas spend a lot of time
with Mishima and he did some great stuff
and you know he's kind of this constant
along the whole journey and he's trying
to help out in the ways that he can and
it's I think definitely for more of a
relationship with him than with her
oh [ __ ] I think this might be where we
actually diverge in opinions oh yes
finally yes no consensus
I like Haru a lot and I yeah I do I do
understand that like she does come in
like way too late in the story and
that's unfortunate but I think that like
one she got when she got introduced I
was like okay I know this is late in the
game so I need a dedicate a lot of time
to her and what you do I think that it
pays off because of course she also has
a very traumatic background and that you
want to be familiar with I think is like
there are so many characters who have
traumatic pasts and you know how is
another one of those that I think I I
don't find how relatable because she's
she's so rich you know and like then you
have like Joker who's like living in an
attic like next to like sacks of like
flour whatnot and that's just a fair
point come come hang with us but we're
never gonna be on the same page you know
what I mean sure okay all right I I
guess I forgot about that you know I I
don't I don't see money you know when I
want to what I meet somebody it's like
you know
I see past that I have said before in a
video that I watched that I did for
persona 5 back when it came out that
Mishima wasn't knowing but I actually
like him more than horror yeah I never
really I didn't get enough time to build
the bond with Haru past the point where
she was the superficial elements of like
her trauma and kind of like what you was
saying Lucy and I I know how much it
pays off in these in these confidant
bonds to get to the end and see like
their full arc and I didn't get to that
point and as annoying as Mishima is I
appreciate how earnest and supportive he
is and so I'm gonna have to go with him
so we've got some what possibly shady
medical clinic arena tighter cami and
Futaba I'm really interested in which
one you get you guys gonna go for here I
like to come here a lot she's very cool
she's trying to help people in you know
unorthodox ways but nonetheless I never
really gelled with Futaba as much as the
rest of the persona fan community seemed
to mainly because I really don't like
those annoying like geek girl archetypes
sure yeah I guess she's helpful in
common and stuff but I yeah I don't know
it's all she's also has a weed
elationship with you where she's like
technically you're like stepsister or
whatever and she's like getting really
close to you and I always found that a
little bit too awkward
so boy I got some anime for you oh it's
not it's not what you think
nevermind nevermind but I definitely I
guess I saw through that because the
whole way through is like I already know
like I didn't even know if she was a
romance option and if she will if when I
found her she was like well that's that
is a listen listen that's not it's not
for to stop from yes am i joking but
I think the like yeah she dude she's a
gamer come on we're gamers right she's
too strong yeah yeah I definitely see
like that the archetype is being
annoying I didn't think it was too bad
with Futaba of course she's she plays a
lot more of a central role given that
she is in the Phantom thieves and I
think the thing I remember a lot about
her is how her support her support moves
came in clutch in so many moments when I
played the game
like there were boss battles where I'm
like damn I did I I'm gonna need to heal
all hopefully I my healer doesn't get
knocked out in the next turn and then
she would come in with like one of her
support abilities and pick everyone back
up and it was kind of yes it's a it's a
combat mechanic and that's like the best
time for it to kick in but when you see
it kind of come together it's like oh
damn we really end this all together
actually I feel like problematic in
similar ways like the annoyingness of
Futaba pulls it down the fact that two
chemi experiments on you pulls it down
but Futaba is as you said great in
battle and sick Hemi has a really good
story with how she's been ostracized for
all this [ __ ] she didn't do being
nicknamed the Black Death like the way
that plays out is very satisfying it was
one of the more memorable stories for me
I'm I'm really torn I feel like if the
Cammy was actually in the phantom feeds
she would be a bit of support at the
time yeah cuz when you level her up
enough you get access to some really
good support items don't you yeah for
top of me I didn't like Ed said I didn't
gel with her as much as a lot of the
persona 5 fandom seems to have done
obviously enjoyed her being there and I
think in battle she was super useful but
in the real world and not in the meta
verse I was never really compelled to
follow her story alone I was never kind
of good I really want to check in with
photography which is about because I did
find her a little bit
I did like the way that she's introduced
to you though it's kind of this this
hacker who's uh you know he's bugging
you and leaving you weird messages I did
like that but I think overall I prefer
goth doctors storyline okay well we got
another phantom safe in the next matchup
we've got Yusuke and he Fumito gay so
that's so Jeep's I am very cute very
nice girl but she's not used a no use
case sucks I was like I know but I love
him so much like it broke my heart I
couldn't romance him I don't know why
yeah I would have
I wouldn't romance him too I just liked
that it was the same voice actors McCree
[Laughter]
yeah you scared higher noon Thai noon on
this tarot card then I'm gonna make for
you no I just didn't gel with him at all
he really annoyed me
the way that he was so oh I don't know
pretentious yes he's a lot he's very
intense he's he's pretentious and I
think that world is just something I
know nothing about and for a character
who's that pretentiousness is just like
bleeds into everything he does from the
way that he talks to where he moves the
way he thinks about other people to he
has really weird views about other
people yeah and it's just it's just very
frustrating it's I just didn't like him
at all and I never used him in battle
either cuz I just couldn't bring myself
to know I think his I honestly his
confident level I think with my Joker
was two or three
which is yeah I just know yeah I
generally don't like that beautiful man
archetype and anime and Yusuke is a very
extreme one of those but he foo me like
I quite I really enjoyed her ah you know
she's got the whole thing of like her
mother pushing her like into one way
where she wants to be something else you
know and that whole thing of like being
yourself in you know all that stuff is
let me we can really get behind
especially in persona yeah you know I
think he for meto go I think is the edu
gonna relate to this is the embodiment
of what it's like to have Asian parents
well exactly exactly yeah and and the
thing too is in the game like ain't
nobody parents anywhere I mean like
Futaba obviously has so gyro but their
relationship is often obviously very
different and he from otago like always
reminded me of like of that that Asian
parent stereotype and for her to break
away from them like oh finally someone's
parents in an anime are in their life
but in a way to kind of communicate like
that theme of rebellion that persona 5
is obviously known for and she's yeah I
like her design too and I think there
was there was like talks about how she
was supposed to be a phantom thief and I
think about what she could possibly be
if she was and that's really fun and
yeah like like her design I like her arc
and you know the arguments against
Yusuke like I I I liked you skate but I
can't argue against the cases that were
made against in so away he's on his own
he's a problematic fave but clearly not
the favor of this conversation and that
is fine
all right so that brings us down to the
last elimination of the first round and
I don't know if you guys know who we
missed but we've got Ryu G and Cao
wakame so your teacher who is also a
maid and your best mate I think I think
I know where I stand on this I think I
know where all y'all stand on this but
Yugi is maybe best boy in the game yeah
yeah so I mean that's it quite like
right me as like problematic as that
whole thing was like I enjoyed spending
time with her and like helping her out
she's so much such a vulnerable adult
you know it's it's very endearing even
that yes super useful abilities to like
being able to slack off her glass and
get other stuff done is really useful
yeah I was stop stacking mad curry cuz
then she be like a come over and cook me
a dish and then I could take that to the
Metaverse which is also problematic Wow
Wow
yeah again another problematic face you
know you know what is so like I was I
was reading up to refresh my mind cuz
obviously been a while since the game
came out and huh oh God so what's really
dark wasn't it and she's stuck in that
awful situation I think she's the better
representation of the tired adult then
oh yeah was cuz and she's just like yo I
got it t she's dumbass kids
damn and I got no money so Cobb akame is
a good representation of capitalism and
how terrible with his so I'll give her
that
and look listen I was like she's kind
she's kind of the one if like I was the
Phantom thief mr. Joker if that was if
that was me I'd be like oh yeah we're
both adults you know I'm saying I'm not
going to school so what's up with it
like I respect the grind wow she's like
har
working and like yo yeah I was like I'll
be down to help her out
well it turns out that I am a 17 year
old high school student so what he can
do so now we've got Mikoto and away if
it was just done you can say it's just
done it's okay the next matchup is zero
and on so I know that I romanced on and
she has a special place in my heart but
I'm gonna honestly go for soujiro
because not only is he looking after one
kid he's looking after - he's trying to
just trying to run his business and you
know have his own life but he's got a
big enough heart that he takes on these
two youths with a lot of baggage
admittedly does get paid for taking on
Joker right just got a little bit money
there yeah he's getting some
compensations what I'm saying but he's I
don't know he's a kind of a ray of hope
I guess in that not all adults are gonna
be horrible yeah like yeah bye-bye again
he kind of takes them all on and says
hey you know my coffee shop is your your
home too so like well I'll hang up the u
s-- k's mom's portrait on the side here
and like kind of over time it becomes
like obviously becomes the hideout but
like visually to you it kind of becomes
a hideout so you'll see people hanging
out there you'll have the painting like
Morgan is invited to stay there so I
think he's a he's a he's a good balance
to the the theme of shitty adults so I
do give him that you know so just seems
heavy [ __ ] together to mostly like he
was mentioning Keller calming oh yeah
who seemed to be tumbling off a cliff at
all times where surger kind of has a
hold and everything even though you
might be struggling he's still like you
know
he's doing a good job Wow a week yeah on
is that what's happening right now
I mean like no one say let's take about
a real quick though like you know it's
that's this was really hot and cold with
that like you know she has a lot of
redeeming qualities about her walk and
it is very easy to empathize with it
there were a lot of points where I was
like I don't know I just wasn't really
feeling it
I didn't couldn't relate to her struggle
as much as I could other people's and I
guess that's what sort of puts it under
so char on stands watching this I'm so
sorry about what has happened to you
Maeve let's cover the wounds by moving
on we got Mishima and túcume annoying
volleyball kid and goth doctor matcha
fight as helpful as he was it's still
pretty annoying and I'm fine in my eyes
that's his downfall and be as helpful as
you want but I don't want it I'm not
actively going on spend time with you
that's why I'm only doing it to be nice
yeah cuz you're doing me a solid but no
there are other people I'd rather hang
out with in golf doctor
yeah oh she's she's she's one of them
and they're like calling back to the
things that we mentioned about to camis
Social Link arc is I mean not say that
mission was arc isn't isn't real or
isn't like it's if if it connects with
someone out there like I don't want it
downplay that but based on our
conversations a it can't be like she's
we like her and I think that's I would
definitely and it kind of speaks to how
I spent time with the game because I
maxed her social link out and not
Mishima so I know her my where I stand
on this
all right okay well let's do the last
round of the second round bracket I
really should just decide how I'm
referring to these we've got here for me
and Reggie would I think this is the
toughest one yet yeah this one's really
talking but I think I know where I stand
on this so so we didn't get a chance to
talk about Ryuji cuz we all knew like
8lm was gonna advance
so now we can MIT yeah we can dig into
it man like his his whole arc is really
wild him like going back to cuz him and
on are actually both the catalysts to
the to the beginning of the game and the
struggles that he faced or the injustice
is that he faced in the beginning of the
game like why he's so brash why so damn
loud and obnoxious for me I was kind of
like yo chill out man and but of course
over time you kind of understand why
he's that way I like his energy he's got
a really good energy and I really wish I
had a shounen friend to help motivate me
throughout life uh he's going up against
him sue me right yeah and what yeah I
really like her Fermi's arc but I think
in this clash of personalities like he's
he's just got way more to him
unfortunately which is unfair but that's
how this thing is going to shake out I
think
he's loud he's brash but he's got a
heart of gold and he is in my party
every single time I go to fight so you
know he's got my vote
so the matchup for the semi-finals the
first semi-final is Makoto and Syd zero
so Jerome parent supporter Makoto Huy oh
yeah you lived the good life he had a
good run is he out well what happened
all the conversation about how it's such
a great Guardian Wow titoo kami and Ryu
G oh this is interesting I deeply adore
Reggie I generally don't like that kind
of character that very like abrasive
young dude I have a script that I never
made into a video somewhere that is just
about how Yugi taught me about how it
must feel to be in a bromance like the
friendship now's the time thank you
with him I felt like is one of the most
affecting like true true friendships
that isn't like muddied by any like
romantic prospects or I mean they're
both coming from the same point and they
have so much respect for each other and
how much they learn from each other like
sitting down and like going out to ramen
with him it's like I haven't played the
game so long in the thing I probably
remember most is like that that true
like authentic friendship with 3G as
much as I wanted to smack the [ __ ] out
of them at some points in the game you
know it's anybody like you
you have arguments with your best bro
exactly
it's yeah I think we read you out of all
of like the best bro characters and the
last few personas like your ska like Jim
pay like Rudy's fine above all of those
guys he's just saying way more
forgivable way more he's a much more
complex he's yeah it's much more fun to
hang out with not as annoying
he does have annoying moments but yeah
like I said he's very easy to forgive
it's pretty unfair to put like the the
phantom thieves against the non phantom
thieves because there is do spend so
much more time with them there is so
much more complexity to them the Reedy
is an achievement I think I hate to
break it to you but we appear to have
arrived at best boy and best girl and I
don't know why I'm surprised that this
has happened but it has we've got Reggie
and Mikado down being the grand final in
the final round is it your greatest love
of your life or your best friend it's
it's it's it's all down to it she's got
like big Hermione Granger energy in the
you also kind of see that up tight miss
unravel over time and you kind of get to
see the real Mikoto and she's just as
messed up as everyone else's and she
doesn't have all she doesn't have like
she she keeps everyone in line but she
doesn't have all the answers which is
also really refreshing for a character
and she just is struggling with so much
and yet has I think the coolest
Metaverse appearance I'm leaning towards
uh Mikoto obviously but I think that if
I were to compare the two confidant arcs
I do like Ryu jeez a bit more like
lakotas is fine and I think that you
learn a lot about about her the things
that she cares about and how she
approaches problems with the things that
she actually does care about but I felt
a little like disassociated from like
that one character she was fighting for
I think was like one of your classmates
and she attends student council meetings
every now and then she's kind of like an
airhead but gets into some trouble and
Mikoto kind of comes in to guide her and
get get her out of trouble and it's very
representative of who she is and why she
is that way but Ryo Gees story does
resonate with me more
because of his like messed up family
situation and just how he how much he
had lost as like a 16 15 year old kid
who had like the world in front of him
and how he copes with that but I bow
down but I like them they're both very
strong characters I you know I I liked
makoto's arc because they robbed
different worlds so it's it's hard to
compare you know they unlikely friends
they would have never associated it with
each other and I don't know it's it's so
tough yeah what is your heart saying my
heart is miqo'te because he was always
my first pick and he was always my
second pick that's my opinion that's my
team yeah there's just something Mikoto
feels so like fleshed out she's just
she's the character that you keep
wanting to hang out with like every time
I had the opportunity it's like okay
Mike Odom I couldn't look at it we have
two Maxima Karthik like that was the
thing and then Ryoji right off Duff but
he was off to us so I have to say
McCarter I love you were Eugene but my
heart says miqo'te well I guess it's
only natural that you know codename
Queen is the queen I don't know what
else we're expecting I hope anyone who
watches extremely what will probably be
a very long videos looking forward to
the fact that we've decided what we
decided in the first 30 seconds of the
video which is that Mikoto is our
favorite but do let us know who is your
favorite down in that comment section
and what mistakes that we made what who
would you choose separately who would
should have been in this bracket that
you think could have given Mikoto a run
for her money let us know but thanks so
much guys for having this very very
important conversation with me this is
very it was heartwarming and it was a
great exercise and it reminded me of why
I love this game so much so yeah that
was fun thank y'all
you